in this video we're going to introduce
ourselves to the idea of photo electron
spectroscopy it's a way of analyzing the
electron configuration of a sample of a
certain type of atom and so what you'll
often see and you might see something
like this on an exam is a photoelectron
spectrum that looks something like this
and so the first question is well what's
even going on how is this generated well
I'm not going to go into the details but
the big picture is the analysis will be
done by taking a stream of that atom and
so that atom there's an atom stream
going in one direction and in the other
direction and let me label this so
that's that's the atoms that we're
trying to analyze and then the other
direction
you send high-energy photons that are
going to bombard those atoms photons now
these photons are high enough energy in
fact there are typically x-ray photons
so that when they collide the photons
are high enough energy to overcome the
binding energy of even the core
electrons and as those electrons get
knocked out they move away and they
enter into a magnetic field that will
deflect those electrons and then make
them hit a detector and so you can
imagine the electrons that are closer to
the nucleus those have the highest
binding energy and so more of that
energy from the photon is going to be
used to knock it off so less of it is
going to be there for the kinetic energy
so those closer electrons aren't going
to get as far and the outer electrons
those have the lowest electron binding
energy they're the easiest to knock off
and so you have more of the photons
energy is going to be transferred into
kinetic energy and so they're going to
get further away and they're going to
hit the detector at a further point and
so one way to view the photo electron a
spectrum is it gives you a sense of
roughly how many electrons have various
binding energies and you can see that
the binding energy increases as we go to
the left now the reason why the
makes sense the binding energy is
inversely proportional to how much
kinetic energy these electrons have as
they actually get knocked off and so
this spike on our spectrum at the
extreme left these are the innermost
electrons and then these would be
electrons further out with the next
lower binding energy and then lower
binding energy after that and so we can
analyze this to actually come up with
the electron configuration of this
mystery element right over here what do
you think that would be pause this video
and try to think about that well as I
mentioned this spike right over here
would correspond to detecting the
innermost electrons and so the innermost
electrons are the 1s electrons and we
know that those aren't the only
electrons because there's electrons that
have lower binding energies and so we
know that we would have filled up that
inner most shell and so we know that
they have two 1s electrons and then we
can then think that this next spike
that's going to be the 2's electrons and
we have more electrons than that so we
must have filled up the 2 s sub shell
and then this next bike this looks like
2p and the reason why this really makes
a lot of sense is notice the detector is
detecting more electrons there and we
also have more electrons and so that
must have been filled and that makes
sense and actually the way this was
constructed it's not always going to be
this perfect but you can see you have
roughly three times as many 2p electrons
as two or less 2's electrons which makes
sense
the 2p sub-shell can fit six electrons
to s subshell fits two so this next
spike is going to be the next highest
energy shell which is going to have a
lower binding energy it's easy to knock
though it's easier to knock those
electrons off and so this looks like
it's going to be the 3 s 2 and then this
next bike this looks like 3 p6 and then
that one gets completely filled and we
have one more spike after that and that
spike seems to get roughly the same
number of electrons as all of the other
s sub shells and we know from the alpha
bottle principle that the next we would
fill is 4 s and it looks like there's
two electrons there
because this bike is about the same as
the other filled s subshells and so just
like that we're able to use the
photoelectron spectrum to come up with
the electron configuration of this
mystery element it's electron
configuration is 1s2 2s2 2p6 3s2 3p6 4s2
and what element has this electron
configuration well we've worked on it in
other videos but I can get my periodic
table of elements out and we can see
let's see 1 s 2 gets us to helium then
you have 2s2 2p6 gets us to neon 3s2 3p6
gets us to argon and then for s 2 gets
us to calcium so our mystery element is
calcium and if someone were to ask about
valence electrons that would be this
outermost spike right over here the
spike of electrons with the lowest
binding energy they had the lowest
binding energy because they're the
furthest out there they are the easiest
to knock off and because they're easiest
to knock off more of that photon energy
is left over after overcoming the
binding energy that gets converted into
kinetic energy so those electrons get
deflected further now based on what we
see here the photoelectron spectrum of
calcium what would we expect the
photoelectron spectrum of potassium be
and just as a reminder potassium has an
atomic number of 19 so it has 19 protons
in the nucleus while calcium has 20
protons in the nucleus and we're going
to assume that we're talking about a
neutral potassium atom so it's going to
have 19 electrons as well pause this
video and think about how it might be
different when we think about potassium
is going to have a very similar
photoelectron spectrum as calcium but
because it only has 19 versus 20 protons
it has less positive charge in the
nucleus so it pulls a little bit less
hard on our various shells so in
potassium you're still going to have 1s
too but it's going to have a slightly
lower binding energy because it's not
pulled in to the nucleus as much and I'm
not drawing it perfectly it might not be
this
watch actually it's probably more slight
probably something like this but it's
going to be a little bit to the right
similarly to s2 it's going to be a
little bit to the right and then to p6
is going to be a little bit to the right
and once again I'm not drawing it
completely perfectly because I don't
have the exact data here 3s2 would be a
little bit to the right once again only
19 protons versus 24 calcium so we're
pulling a little bit less inwards so we
have a lower binding energy for any
given shell or sub shell and 3p6 is
going to be a little bit to the right
like this and then what is the for s
subshell going to look like well it
doesn't have two electrons in the four S
sub shell it only has one because we
only has 19 electrons and not 20 and so
it's going to be a little bit to the
right it has a lower binding energy and
it's only gonna be half as high because
you only have one electron not two so
it's going to look something like that
that would be the photoelectron spectrum
of potassium roughly speaking now we've
already talked about that your outermost
shell
shows where your valence electrons are
so if we're thinking about potassium it
would be right over there now that also
tells us when we're talking about the
binding energy over here so this binding
energy that tells us how much energy do
we need to remove an electron and so
when you're removing that first electron
that's your first ionization energy once
you remove that first electron because
of all of the interactions between the
electrons your photoelectron spectrum
would change so you can't think about
your second or third ionization energies
but your first ionization energy you
just have to think about it's the
binding energy of your outermost
electrons